[ __ ] go with this poly [ __ ] again
oh yeah shots why you orp my friend
never talked to strangers i was taught
that as a kid and even if the score even
[ __ ] i'ma always win we put this [ __ ]
in here
wearing george's mic'd up like mj shells
left from dancing in the mirror like mj
this chop got a black belt or a piece
insane
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you are not a threat i
knew the [ __ ] wasn't known
[ __ ] when he shot a text bro it was
simply for the gram
i thought that if i did she would've
give me some more fans bro i'm truly
sorry why you orp my friend
better luck next time but don't try that
[ __ ] again look first off
that never even happened that [ __ ] you
talking about really sounds like
entrapment
that'll never happen even if i'm off a
batman another reason i'm
in this song is stop rapping stop
capping
[ __ ]
i banned doing this [ __ ] these little
[ __ ] dreaming about i popped the perk
now i feel like jesus now
effingham bullets knocking all my demons
down a fuselage flying with the eagles
now
and even marcus shopping i just spent a
couple thousand my wrists look like i
could have bought a house with it your
[ __ ] looking stylish cuz he see my
whole neck listen
nick from england [ __ ] i put a whole
pound keep the snakes around me don't
like judas is around [ __ ]
smoking on zod we don't do the black and
mountain play me like i'm sweet cause
i'm up we going down these
i'm really tired all these go tools and
clowning just because i got hit by your
[ __ ] don't let that bother you
i don't know why you hit the [ __ ] she
was honest doing you can come around
gang your [ __ ] will tolerate juicy
you know
[Music]